Diego Vallejo came up with the slogan
from another galaxy and from this
neighborhood to celebrate his childhood
friend Leonard Messi
when we were kids with Leo this was a
garbage dump but in time we restored it
and now we have 32 murals celebrating
him
they grew up together here in La bajada
a working-class neighborhood of Rosario
Diego says it was safer back then in the
last decade violence has skyrocketed due
to a drug war but tourists still come
here to take pictures and listen to the
stories of the young Messi playing on
the neighborhood streets
he still carries that child inside of
him the humbleness he's still the same
childhood and education the first step
in life to find you forever we were
naughty and happy around here
Messi's out of this world Talent was
apparent even when he was the smallest
kid in his classroom
over the years he made a range of
donations to his Elementary School
his teacher proudly shows the picture of
his fifth grade class
he would anxiously Wait For Recess to
play with his friends everybody wanted
to play on his side because he was so
good it was always difficult to bring
him back to class I remember a teacher
telling him there was only one Maradona
unaware of who she had in her class
and his story keeps providing
inspiration to new generations
Messi played for six years here for the
Youth side of Newell's old boys one of
Rosario's two main clubs scoring
hundreds of goals before becoming a
superstar at Barcelona his then Coach
still gets emotional remembering him no
no no I taught him nothing up to this
day I keep seeing small things he keeps
pulling out from this magic baggage of
knowledge he holds somewhere it's a gift
from God
few football players have achieved as
much as Messi has since leaving La
bajada 13 yet a World Cup win has always
eluded him putting him under extreme
pressure to do so
we all share the same wish and it goes
beyond argentinians there are many many
people around the world that want Leo to
be the champion he deserves it
at 35 this could be Messi's last chance
of winning the World Cup for his
hometown and the entire country it would
be the icing on the cake of his
otherworldly career Alessandra Al
Jazeera Rosario Argentina